donc on peut suivre un petit tutoriel
pour expliquer comment fonctionne
l'application puis on bascule un basset
mairie ce sera la nouveauté est la
marque de la modernité dans ce château
vieux 2000 une société française basée à
paris a travaillé d'arrache-pied pendant
près d'un an pour éditer sur des
tablettes une reconstitution des plus
fidèles du château des comtes du perche
saisissant le projet de nogent était au
début conçu pour présenter une
application de visites vraiment immersif
pour tout le château et présentant des
reconstitutions 3d l'intérêt de la
réalité augmentée c'est que on va
pouvoir à nouveau reconstituer
s'immerger dans le donjon tel qu'il est
est là notamment en 1990 quand a eu lieu
là la négociation est la rencontre entre
richard coeur de lion et philippe
auguste
n'a proposé également se sont donc
l'utilisation de casques pour coupler à
la fois de la réalité virtuelle avec les
casques et la réalité augmentée avec les
tablettes
donc ça permet aux visiteurs de pouvoir
découvrir de manière ludique le château
sous différents bien et il ya la
spécificité aussi c'est qu'il ya un
parcours vraiment pour les enfants axé
sur les jeux donc vous avez un jeu eux
mêmes de géocaching à l'intérieur du
château va falloir découvrir une cache
qui me permet d'accéder à un code pour
avoir accès à la suite du parcours
la reconstitution s'est comme un
parcours initiatique qui permet une
tablette à damas de voyager dans le
passé et le présent
un peu plus d'une heure pour en faire le
tour
je trouve que c'est très bien
reconstituée parce qu'on a l'habitude de
reconstitution dans des livres là pour
la première fois on a l'impression que
ici à nogent on peut vraiment faire
tourner la tablette et visualiser la
pièce telle qualité donc c'est quand
même c'est nouveau et ça fait bienvenue
au musée du perche mille ans d'histoire
vous contemplent on a une mise en avant
de la grande époque qui ont marqué
l'histoire du château vous avez
le moyen âge avec la période des comptes
du perche qui ont participé aux
croisades notamment avec des urnes
funéraires des sauts des monnaies des
armes une partie plus centré sur la
renaissance
c'est d'ici que le prince de condé est
parti pour prendre d'assaut orléans 15
162 et ça a été le déclenchement de la
première guerre de religions et de le
signal du soulèvement des protestants et
des huguenots à travers toute la france
le musée de l'histoire du perche est
ouvert tous les jours de la semaine sauf
le mardi de 10h à 12h et de 14h à 18h